i think for the most part especially
with the um
the address he gave last week i think
biden has looked
capable i'm not i don't think he's
looked strong or tough but it looked
like he's making sense and yeah i can't
i agree i can't disagree with the way we
have been handling the situation i
cannot
um
now
the only thing
that
clear thinking
people
disagree with is that we we're not
opening up
the american oil spigot again
right which i think is coming i think
that's the next step because we just put
a ban on
russian oil right right and i think
we're too busy courting
iran and venezuela and everybody else
why would we open up our own pipelines
yeah i mean that's that that right there
if you think about that that is the
matter of fact i'll read that story go
to page two down gino
uh uh papa papa which one is that banjo
don't you think yes
administration courts venezuela iran and
saudi arabia by the administration of
course venezuela i ran in saudi arabia
for oil while ignoring u.s producers the
has found themselves in a position where
they need more oil
production to lower gas prices but can't
do that domestically without alienating
the large anti-fossil fuel portion of
the base and breaking their own promises
at gas prices top four dollars
nationally and seven dollars in some
cities they're instead opting to beg
venezuela iran and saudi arabia for
bailout this comes days after biden
proved the release of 30 million barrels
from the strategic petroleum reserve for
reference 30 million barrels isn't even
enough to cover two days of u.s oil
consumption with the possible exception
of saudi arabia biden would rather fund
a list of america's enemies than boost
our own oil industry
so so you got russia what they're going
through you got us how we're reacting to
economical crisis that we're having here
today right these are two different
things that's going on that's putin
this is u.s and biden every time he's
asked he was asked a question yesterday
i don't know if he saw that tyler he was
asked are gas prices going to go up yes
what are we doing about it we can't do
nothing about it it's because of russia
he said that yesterday in a
question back i don't know if you saw
that or not person asking that question
so
lower and middle income families are
paying a price for this that's what
that's who's paying a price for that
that's a completely different
conversation though this this is another
case where uh um
ideology is trumping reason and i'm not
using trump because of donald trump this
is
this is an ideology
the queening of the world
it it no matter how you look at it
what we're doing here doesn't make any
sense
because
american companies
pump oil cleaner and produce whatever
the the derivative of oil much cleaner
than all the other countries
so
it doesn't make it doesn't make any
sense there's it's no clear thinking
it's an ideology it's a religion so if
you enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]
you